waiting for the government to solve
problems is usually a long wait
entrepreneurs on the other hand you know
we're the ones out there building jobs
trying to enhance communities for people
have money to invest in the local
economy spins around
and we don't wait for government
entrepreneurs don't wait for government
you know and in fact entrepreneurs often
succeed despite government despite High
interest rates and Times of inflation
and recession I was part of a company
that we went out during the nuclear
winter for the economy in 2000 2001 and
we went out got eight and then 10
million dollars in Venture Capital to
drive a company forward why because we
had a great company with a great team to
approved we have traction it was working
and there were people that said there's
not zero investment going on there is
venture capital investment but it's only
to the best who show that they can if
they could do it in this economy they
can do it in any economy